All right. Welcome Google New York.
Thank you so much for joining us today.
I'm Jessie Haynes. I'm the director
of product for the Google good theme,
which is a team that makes
tech accessories for Google
hardware and I am third
build it to be joined here
today by Randy Zuckerberg.
Thanks guys.
I am thrilled to be here and even I'm
wearing polka dots and honor of, uh, my,
my new show. It's just like, oh man,
I can't wait to talk all about it.
A brief introduction. Randy
is an entrepreneur, investor,
bestselling author and media personality.
I'm an early employee at Facebook.
She led major marketing initiatives in
the company his formative years and has
gone on against my, you
guys. I'm so, I was like,
am I allowed in the building when I
signed him? That's good. Thank you.
But yes,
those,
not that she's gone on to
launch Zuckerberg media
with the mission of creating
media content that's puts
intelligent tech savvy,
entrepreneurial women and
girls at the forefront.
She has published two books.
Dot.
Complicated and New York
Times bestseller and dot.
A Children's book about
a tech savvy little girl,
which we're going to talk about today
and which you are able to purchase after
this session back. Um,
in addition to books,
Randy is an executive producer
on three television shows,
all the holds a business talk radio
show on Sirius Xm and has performed on
Broadway, which I think is just
the coolest thing ever. Um,
she is the mother of two boys and a proud
resident of our fair city, New York.
So once again, welcome to
Google radio. Thanks. Um,
so as we were talking about before,
I was thrilled to read the piece that you
wrote in vogue a couple of months back
where you talked about leaving Silicon
Valley and coming here to New York.
So why don't we start there. Tell us a
little bit about what motivated that move,
um, and what's making you happiest here
in the baker or, well, gosh, it was a,
it's a really tough time.
I grew up here in New York.
I grew up in Westchester and, uh, so
I guess a little bridge and tunnel,
but that's okay. Um, and,
uh, I, I always just,
I was one of those New York
snobs where I thought like, wow,
people can be happy outside of New York,
like p,
like people live outside of New York
and not just ironically. Um, and uh,
so then of course I wound up
spending a decade in California.
It wasn't supposed to be a decade.
I thought I'm going to go out and I'm
going to work in silicon valley for a few
months. And then a few months turned into
a decade, a public company to children.
And, um, I,
I never really put down my roots in
California because I always just assumed I
was going back to New York. And finally
I looked at my husband and I was like,
we've been here a decade.
Like we haven't picked a school for
our kids. We don't have friends.
Like we keep talking like, we're
going to move to New York any second.
Like we're at a point where you need
to actually pick a path and do it. And,
um,
I started having kids really
made me take a step back and,
and look a little more at the world
that we lived in. I love Silicon Valley.
It's an increase. I mean, I'm sure all
of us have spent a lot of time out at,
at headquarters and out there and it's
just this heady place of innovation and
excitement and everyone, like,
like, what are we disrupting today?
Whose lunch are reheating?
Yeah. Like it's so fun. But um,
but it's a one industry town.
And what I loved about New York is I love
that you can walk down the street and
see people from every country
speaking every language.
Like I love that kids can learn about
Picasso in school and then walk to a
museum and see your Picasso and,
and there's so many amazing things you
can hit in one day in the city. And, um,
I, at the end of the day,
juggling between the two, I just,
that's what I wanted for my family. That's
what I wanted for myself. I wanted, um,
that, that big city, uh,
not single industry town.
So I'm thrilled to be back.
We've been here about a year and I'm
still in the New York honeymoon phase.
So even,
you know,
like stepping over the cockroaches on
the street and everything. I'm like,
it's a beautiful car garage. So I know
we'll talk about it again in a year.
It's great. Well you're,
you know, it's, it's,
it's great to hear your enthusiasm
and passion for this city.
And I think a lot of us here at Google,
um,
love being New Yorkers and working
at Google New York, but you know,
but the headquarters is in mountain
view and there is always sort of that
pullback since in your year here,
what have been your observations about
the tech scene here in New York and how
that differs from,
one of the things that I love is that I
feel like the city itself here is part
of the tech scene in silicon valley.
It's very separate.
You get on your luxury shuttle bus and
you get busted and then you kind of stay
at headquarters all day and
you have all your meals,
they redo everything and then
you go home. Um, but here we all,
we ride the subway, we were
pool, you know, we like you,
the city itself is as much a part of
the tech culture as the sites that we're
working on and building,
like we come into contact with the
people we are building for every day,
which is not something that always
happens out there in silicon valley.
A lot of times I found that we
had to guess like we, you know,
and often a bunch of times it's early
adopters inside a company that you end up
building things that are just for yourself
because you're not spending that time
with people. So that was, that was
what I thought. It was really exciting.
I think also because a lot
of the investors and the
VC's out here come from a
more traditional finance background.
Like they, they want to fund,
I'm not sure how to say this 100% nicely.
The livestream.
They want to fund real businesses and
real businesses that will grow over the
long term. Um, so there, I've
found that investors here, they're,
they're okay with companies that take
a decade to build because they're in it
for the long haul.
That's what they've seen.
That's what they've known or is in Silicon
Valley because a lot of the investors
used to be founders, entrepreneurs
themselves. There's that mindset of like,
turnaround a company quickly,
create something, sell it, do this.
They're not in it for the long
term as much out here as I see
in New York.
So in that vogue piece,
you talked about how being in New York
has allowed you to bring together tech,
performing arts,
entrepreneurial women,
and even just sort of
seeing your bio again today,
I just am dazzled by all
of the fascinating sort of
things that you've got going
in your on in your life, TV
show, on oxygen, a radio show,
your books,
and now your children's book.
Dot is being turned into a kids show.
Um,
which one of these projects is your
favorite? Or is that just, oh my gosh,
it's really hard to,
but I think, um, it all kind
of stems from the same place.
And after again, uh, being in
Silicon Valley with amazing.
But one thing I love about
being here in New York,
like I look out at the same room at all
of these incredible women that are here.
And uh, it was, it got lonely
at times in Silicon Valley.
Uh,
I remember in the early days of working
there I would send emails to people for
meetings and I guess they thought Randy
was a guy and I'd show up and people
would be visibly disappointed for a
young woman to walk into the room. And,
uh,
after I left Facebook and I took some
time to think about what my next step was,
I thought I was going to go right into
building my own social media company.
I think everyone thought I
was going to do that too.
And I took some time to realize,
okay,
how do we actually get
more women in the room? Um,
a lot of people have a lot of ideas on
this and the hypothesis I kept coming
back to was that maybe it comes from
pop culture. Maybe it comes from media,
maybe it comes from young girls seeing
role models to look up to on screen that
are tech savvy and
entrepreneurial and smart.
And so instead of diving right into
doing my own social media company,
I created Zuckerberg media. I'm
thinking, how could I put more smart,
intelligent tech savvy women
and girls into pop culture? Um,
and that's why I have my hand in so
many things because as we all know,
our audiences everywhere,
they're not just watching one TV channel,
they're not just on one website. So,
um, I felt I needed to be on the radio.
I needed to have my hand in TV
shows on different channels.
I needed to be creating
content for online. And uh,
but every morning I wake up and I
think about how infuse more, uh,
women and girls into pop culture.
Tell us a little bit more about the book.
What was obviously that I came
from the same place, but how,
why a children's book and then how did
the TV show happened? I was actually,
I was writing a business book at the time.
I didn't even mean to
write a children's book.
I was writing a business book called Dot
complicated because I think what we all
understand is that tech has changed
every aspect of our lives. You,
this room is responsible for that.
Um,
in so many wonderful ways.
It's created so much opportunity in
our lives, in our businesses. Um,
but tech also sometimes makes us want
to rip her hair out of our head and
frustration. And, uh, it's changed the
way we parent. I feel like here I was,
I was writing a book it from the
perspective of a tech expert.
And yet I was a purely a,
a mature mom when it came to
raising kids in the digital age.
And I looked at my son and how he
was engaging with tech and I thought,
oh my gosh, if I wait until people can
read dot complicated, it's too late.
I need to start with a children's book.
So I created dot,
which is about a super techie little girl,
but she learns to find balance.
So in the beginning of the book,
it's like dot.
Knows how to swipe and tap and search.
Um,
and then she goes outside and when
she's Swiping, she's finger painting.
And when she's tapping,
she's dancing and searching,
just playing hide and go seek. So, um,
it's really important for that was a
really wonderful project for me. And, uh,
when I got the opportunity to collaborate
with the Jim Henson Company and NBC to
actually turn the show
from a book, uh, turn,
turn it from a book
into a show 52 episodes,
which is really exciting. So, um, I,
I jumped at the opportunity,
I have crazy respect for like Pixar and
everyone in animation now after seeing
how much work it takes to create one 10
minute episode of this show and seeing,
uh, the beautiful animation that
happens in films, but it's, um,
it's just been the coolest experience
that's so exciting. And this,
and it premieres at the 22nd of all, it
does this Saturday. Um, but it's like,
imagine walking into a startup like
with the giant screens and everything,
but dot.
It's on every screen.
Like that's what I felt when I walked
into the animation house. Like I had,
it felt very emotional.
She's the daughter I never had.
And of course here I am doing all this
like feminist content and I have two sons,
but it's great. I know me too. But
our boys will like. Dot. Right.
Exactly. Oh yeah, man. I mean my son was
two when the book came out. Now he's five.
And so he's basically grown up with dot.
He feels real ownership for this
character is, uh, it's pretty exciting.
But so just to give you a sense of
the show, like dot and her friends,
they don't do anything the way normal
kids do tech pluses up, everything.
So all the other kids on the block might
be having a lemonade stand buttoned
dots and delivers via drone because why
would she forced the customer to come to
the lemonade when the, she could scale by
the lemonade going to the customer. Um,
so every episode you see dot.
And her group of friends using
technology in a really funny way.
And uh, and it's, it's great.
We even have like a Pokemon go
inspired episode, which is fine.
Love that.
Um,
so you do have a lot going on.
and I think a lot of us here
have a lot going on. Um,
how do you, and you know
sometimes how do you balance it,
balance it all or, or, or do you,
and I think I was found a tweet from,
from uh,
a while back where you said
the entrepreneur's dilemma,
maintaining friendships,
building a great company, spending
time with family, staying fit,
getting sleep, pick three. Um,
and I love that because I actually think
that sometimes this focus on balance
sort of sets up unrealistic expectations.
Wait,
and I don't think this is not just a
thing for entrepreneurs or for moms or for
women. I mean this is for everyone in
life. Like I talked to my son, I'm like,
sorry, you can't play in the sandbox
and eat cake at the same time.
Like you have to find balance and picks.
So, but yeah, so that's kind of my mantra.
Every day I wake up and I'm like,
family, friends, fitness, sleep, work,
pick three. And each day you
can only pick three of those.
You can pick a different three each day.
So as long as it balances out over
the long run, it's a, it's okay,
but you really, you can't do all
five of those things well in one day.
And so I think the key
is just, um, you know,
knowing that it's okay to be well
lopsided in the short term as long as you,
you know, are well lopsided the
other direction, the longterm.
And what about technology? Um,
and how an end, you know, you've,
you've written a lot about trying to
figure out the right balance of technology
in our lives and the
importance of unplugging,
which is so easy to say,
but so hard to do
is,
and it's so funny how many of us,
like we have these rules for our
children that we think about.
And then if we kind of looked
into mirrored or own behavior,
like what poor role models
we are of those exact roles.
So it's always funny because I
feel like people always ask, okay,
Randy, what are your rules
for your children? What are
your rules in your house?
But so few people ask me, Randy,
what are your rules for yourself?
And where would they be? Like, you know,
where do they think my children are
learning their behaviors from? So, uh,
I, I remember when Asher, my
oldest son was six months old,
he started picking up a remote,
a TV remote and making texting
thumbs with it. And I was like,
oh gosh, I think I to adjust
my own behavior a little
bit in front of him. So, um,
we definitely have PR,
prolonged periods of unplugging,
which is difficult.
I don't recommend going cold Turkey on
unplugging for anyone that's starting out.
Like the first time I did, I hold my phone
in my hand still for most of the day,
even though I, but sometimes now
I'll even like, I'll go so crazy.
It's like sometimes put my
phone on airplane mode. Whoa.
Um, and uh, but I,
and I've also had to train myself and
the people around me and how I respond to
email because I know,
especially in tech culture,
like there's a lot of pressure to be
always on, to be answering emails.
Someone sends you an email,
you need to respond,
whether it's the middle of the night. And,
and a few minutes later, um, and I, I,
I felt like, okay, no one else is
going to create boundaries for you,
but if you create them yourself,
you will start to train the people
around you how to treat you. So I,
you know, just slowly started to
say like, okay, I'm, you know,
don't respond to emails as quickly
on weekends or to my team. Uh,
you might get an email from me at midnight
and that is not because I expect you
to respond.
That is because like,
that is the first time I've gotten to
myself after I've been able to put my kids
down to bed and do everything else
and that's when I work. So, um,
I think definitely creating those
boundaries back to kids though,
I think there are so many amazing ways
to introduce children to tech that
doesn't require screens all the time.
Uh,
there's so many great toys out there
that have encouraged and still love of
building engineering, coding. We just
bought for our sons the Coda Pillar,
the Fisher price code,
a pillar.
It's this caterpillar and it comes with
all of these interchangeable parts.
Like you code it, you know, go, go left,
go right, make a noise dance and you,
you make a start, a green
start and a red finish. And uh,
the kid has to decide,
okay,
how do I program the parts
of the Caterpillar to get
it to start here and end
here and you can root around.
And so there's like a little robots.
We have all kinds of fun things.
So we definitely do a lot to
encourage a love of programming logic,
uh, engineering in our household while
trying to limit screen time for our kids.
Um, it did not know about the Coda. Yeah.
Lot of felons available on Amazon.
Um, I hope so. Um,
so we talked a little bit about,
um,
women in tech and at Google. We've done
a lot of investigating here on time.
How can we, can we, you know,
address this issue and people have pointed
to the lack of women studying stem in
school as a reason. There
are fewer women in tech. And,
and you've talked about this role model,
um,
sort of lack of role models. What, um,
what do you think in your
observation is, is working, um,
and you know, since you've
taken this sort of media, are
there some,
you know,
how's it been encouraging signs that
you've seen of sort of impact and the tide
changing? Well, first of all,
I think New York is really a place
silicon valley can take a real lesson from
New York and this perspective.
I mean,
we can still do much better with
women and enrolls in tech, but, um,
it's incredible the amount of women in
higher positions in tech female founders
that we're seeing here in New York.
Um,
I also think it's because there's so
many other industries, like I said,
it's not a single industry town.
So we're used to seeing women at the
top of media companies at the top of
publishing houses at the
top of ad agencies. Like,
that's not such a weird thing here as
a as it is. Um, I think it starts a,
I think there's, this is almost
like a multipronged problem, right?
It starts obviously in the house.
Um, it starts in the schools.
It's really,
it's around age seven or eight that all
the studies show that girls suddenly
wake up to the fact that
society is telling them that
they shouldn't be good at
math and engineering and
science. And, uh, so I think it,
it's pop culture. It's our schools is
what they're learning at homes. But then,
I mean, it's definitely also has
to come from, from effort in, uh,
in our companies. Um,
there were, you know,
I recently was talking to a team of
investors out in silicon valley and they
were like, Randy, we really want you to
invest in our fund. And I was like, cool,
you have no female partners. So
like, come back to me when you do.
And they're like, but we tried so hard,
we just like, couldn't find anyone.
I'm like, well, yes, diversity
takes effort. It takes effort,
like try harder and then come back to
me. It's my money. I have a right to, uh,
to decide how I'm going to spend
it and how I'm going to invest it.
So I think it takes people standing up
and saying things like that and that,
you know,
takes reminding people that yes,
diversity does take that little bigger
step of effort, but it's worth it.
Definitely.
Um,
you've led a lot of teams
through your career and, um,
have been regaled as a
strong manager and a mentor.
Tell us about some of the mentors that
you've had in your life. Oh my gosh.
I've been so lucky to have
so many great mentors. Um,
Kathleen Kennedy of
Lucas Film. Um, I mean,
it's incredible to think that the
president of Lucasfilm is a woman. Um,
so she's clearly spent a lot
of time in a man's world, um,
but she has been an incredible
ally and an asset to me. Um,
I recently spent some time to Susie
Orman who just like what, first of all,
I was like,
everything that they portray on
SNL is totally accurate and fun.
But, um, she, you know,
she created such an incredible empire
from nothing on empowering women with
their finances.
And so that was really amazing to learn
from her and get some advice from her in
world. And, um, I've just,
I've also been so lucky,
I've been learning from a lot of the
women, uh, who are at the head of dot.
Like Lisa Henson, who runs Henson, um,
has been an incredible mentor
to me. Navigating La, um,
the head of sprout at NBC as a woman.
So like.is a,
is a real girl power show. And
also like, I love guys too.
Like I see a lot of guys in this audience.
That's awesome. Thanks for supporting.
Amazing. So I've had a
lot of incredible, uh,
male mentors in my life too. And, um, I,
I do think that there's a lot of pressure
on all of us and especially in the
tech world to kind of figure it out
ourselves, do what ourselves do it fast.
But what partnering on projects like Dot
has shown me is that there are a lot of
instances where one plus one equals four.
When you trust people,
when you put your faith and, and, uh, you
accept mentorship from other people. And,
um, I took this asset as far as
I could and it never would have,
it would have stopped there
without including folks
like Jim Henson and sprout.
Yeah.
So it seems only appropriate since you've
been such a proponent of women to take
a little moment to talk about our election
since women have then it's front and
center in so many ways.
In the recent months. Um,
there was a editorial that in the,
in the Times that commented on Michelle
Obama's recent speech in November where
she reflected on the recent happenings.
Um,
and I think the exact was oh,
really beautiful was it wasn't
quite in a remarkable speech. Um,
that misogyny is the midwife of history,
which I thought was a really interesting
way to sort of sum it up. Um,
what are some of your reflections on
what's been happening in this crazy
election and do you
think that come November,
we will have elected the
first woman president.
All right. Well, I, it's
interesting. So my, um,
my kind of emotional connections with
elections started back in the 2008
election. That was my first election
that I really worked on at Facebook.
And actually we worked hand in hand
with Google on, on that election.
And I remember we would big candidates
to get onto social media and most of the
candidates like hung up on
us or we're like, sorry,
we're not interested in the social media
generation. Um, and things like that.
Like I went with the team from Google
and we sat at the Republican National
Convention and no one met with us
for the entire time because like,
no one cared about the internet
and you know, whatever. Um,
and uh,
so it was amazing to me to even fast
forward just a few years to midterm
election and to see that I actually knew
who was running for every office and
before the media or the public did because
the first thing they would do is like
set up their Facebook page
behind the scenes so they
could press click when they,
when they launched their campaign.
Um,
so that was really amazing to me to see
in just that short period of time and
now to look at this election,
which is complete.
Everything is playing out online,
on social media.
Every single aspect of it is
about like what's going viral and,
um, how were we sharing content? And it's,
it's just been incredible for me to see
an eight years how the game has shifted
so completely to people saying we don't
care about the Internet and social media
to an entire election decided
on, on, and by the Internet.
So first of all,
as crazy as it is,
like the Internet has won
this election, so Yay. Um,
but that being said, it
is, uh, it is really crazy.
I don't think any of us could have
believed this and to be totally honest,
I think all of the incredible tools
that all of us have created, um,
have both empowered a world
where anyone could have a voice,
but also created a world
where anyone can have a voice.
And A, we are sort of seeing, like I
said, everything is dot complicated.
Like my book,
we've created tools that have empowered
Arab spring that have given voices to
the voiceless.
But like Donald Trump has a huge voice,
thanks to all the tools
that we've done. Um, and uh,
I so I think that's why it's going
to be really interesting for,
I think all of us to take a step back
after this election plays out and really
think, okay, you know, what are
the positive sides of technology?
What are the downsides?
How should tech be used to build
brands and empower elections?
And, uh, I really,
I really do hope we see a woman in the
White House and two and a half weeks.
Great. So audience, um,
please come to the microphones and we're
going to open this up for questions.
And while that's happening, I just have
a quick speed round for you, right?
You Ready? Awesome. IPHONE or android?
It's okay.
Phone,
but my husband has an android so that
we're both okay. Okay. We'll forgive you.
That's like a new, you know, modern family
uptown or downtown. Uptown
upper west. Google or bing.
Come on.
But funny story though,
I did accidentally get being locked into
my iPhone once for a few weeks and I
was like,
I had to like physically go to google.com
to search for things and I was like,
no. Okay. Hamlet or Hamilton.
Oh my gosh. Okay. Right now
Hamilton. But I am, you know,
a classical girl by heart,
so I am going to have to tie that one.
Okay. Okay. Croissant or
Bagel, what about the mixture?
Don't they have the leg?
Like the breath sounds like?
I'm sure like some bakery is making
that somewhere I want. I want. Okay.
Uber or taxi. Subway. Got,
I'm do like the real New
York getting ready. I only
rarely say whatever's faster.
Totally good answer.
Perfect. All right, great.
We've got some folks at the
mix and let's open it up.
So I have a question
about the women and um,
young girls growing up with this idea
that they're not good at math or science.
Um, I think the first time I heard that
was when I was like out of college.
And frankly, it really surprised me
because growing up my math class,
my advanced math classes,
advanced science classes,
girls probably out numbered
boys and like two to one.
And so I truthfully to always thought
girls who are smarter than boys.
Um,
and I wonder,
I wonder if sometimes if by repeating that
we actually do ourselves a disservice.
Yeah. Rather than just focusing
our energy on things like dot.
And promoting more women in, um,
women in sciences, in the media,
rather than even just acknowledging that.
Because sometimes I get frustrated
when I hear women talking about it more
because I feel like it
perpetuates the myth.
I think you're totally right on that.
And it was interesting when we were
coming up with all the episodes for dot
people,
uh,
some of the people in the writing team
kept pitching episodes that were like,
dot. Overcomes this bias. And
finally, a few of us were like, wait.
Dot doesn't think she's
worse than the boy is. Like,
what bias does she have to overcome?
She doesn't even know that,
that everyone thinks she's not
supposed to measure up. So, um,
we were like kids today,
they don't, that's not even,
why should we put that idea into their
head if that's not in their head already?
So I think you're absolutely right.
I would love to,
to live in a world where that's not
even an issue when I think we are seeing
that more and more with kids that um,
there's not like girl shows
and boys show is or this.
But I think as long as we continue to
walk into toy stores and see like that
pink aisle and that blue while and um,
and Halloween costumes and different
things like that, like that,
that is perpetuating it without us even
thinking we're perpetuating it. Um,
okay.
But I agree. I think less talking
about it is probably the way to go.
What we're doing.
You guys both continents. Hi. Um, hi.
Thank you for coming in. Um,
I'm a mom. I also have two kids.
I have a nine year old son and
a five year old daughter. Um,
and I'm curious if with all of the
initiatives that you're doing around women
and creating a show about girls,
if your sons ever ask you
why you're focused on girls.
My son has started calling me a sexist,
which I think he's picking up from
the Trump stuff. I'm like, okay,
it's not about better than it's equal.
And then my
daughter's there and I don't want her
to hear that we're not equal yet and get
like this weird insecurities.
So I'm curious if your boys have picked
up on your female initial interesting.
My oldest is five,
so maybe he hasn't quite picked up.
He's never mentioned anything
or send anything. He did ask me.
So I went to a high school in New
York called Horace Mann. And uh,
he did ask me when I told him
why it's not called Horace woman.
Um, and I was like, well, that's
like someone's name. Okay,
good. That's great. I was
like, Yay. Raising boys. Um,
but so I don't,
it hasn't been an issue yet.
I mean that being said,
she wanted to come and go as
my little pony for Halloween.
So I know he's definitely not seeing
gender differences in content,
but um,
that is a good question and
I will definitely have to
think about how to respond
to that one when it comes around.
Yes.
Yeah. If you find anything, let us know.
Maybe make another story about, yeah,
I think, I think it's a, it's a
great idea and um, uh, but
it's, it's been funny to see,
we lined up to see the motorcade because
President Obama came to the apartment
building next to us a few minutes ago to
do a fundraising event and he was like
all excited and we were talking about
how well like next it's going to be a
woman's turned to me and the
White House and he's like,
maybe we'll men have a turn.
No, again, one day.
And I was like, probably once the
country sees how awesome women,
they weren't running the problem.
Hey, thanks for being as quite top. Yeah.
My question is around this,
we've kind of moved into this world of
post fact politics or whatever you want
to call it.
And I'm from the UK as you can probably
hear and we just had the Brexit a few
months ago. Um, and all of us as we
scroll through our Facebook feeds,
that's where it feeds youtube,
wherever it might be.
The algorithmic nature of those feeds
means we end up seeing stuff that we want
to see you, right? Yeah. Which is
a good user experience. One extent,
but that also means we're kind of being
insulated and we're not seeing a diverse
range of opinions and that sort of stuff.
So I was curious to see if you had an
opinion on as creators of those products
by Facebook and Google, um, and you know,
entrepreneurs that you're working with,
how can we strike that balance to make
sure that we're inclusive of different
opinions, but no, actually, you know,
making sure I don't see
Donald Trump every day. Ava.
No, it's such a great question because
you're right, we do wind up in these,
these echo chambers of, uh, of
people who think like us. And uh,
on one hand it's so great that millennials
are getting a lot of their news from
social media.
I think millennials,
young people are more informed than
ever before because of how quickly and
easily they can access news. But, um,
I think it's also part of
our responsibility to keep
reminding people that if
you're actually going to get
your news from social media,
makes sure you are following
a diverse group of people. Um,
make sure that you are taking the time
to add people on Instagram and Twitter
and all of these sites that don't
agree with you and that, um,
represent different opinions
because you're right,
it's so easy to fall into that.
I think another kind of sort
of point you brought up,
like the post fact checking era is,
um,
it's also a really interesting world
because the nature of getting content out
fast has made it such that media
companies value getting things out quickly
rather than getting things out.
Right. So I also think it's important,
it's more and more important for all of
us as consumers to start demanding that
quality content.
Because if we are positively reinforcing
this culture where media is just,
okay,
let's get things out for the clicks and
the click bait and the headlines and
fast like it on.
I mean in the long run they're doing what
we want, what we click on, what we like.
So if we start demanding that, that fact
checking that better quality content,
then that's what we're going to get.
Great. Thanks. Thanks.
Hi.
Has Your work brought you to anything
with the digital divide and how that's
affected education?
Yes.
We're actually doing a lot of that with
dod and had been thinking a lot about
that because here we are portraying this
adorable girl on the screen with her
iPad and everything. But we
live in a world where most
kids, they don't, you know,
can't just pick up an iPad at
home. Uh, they can't afford it.
They don't have access to it.
They don't have parents that are
encouraging the tech. So, um,
we really went back to the drawing board
and tried to introduce a whole range of
characters that have different
exposures and different levels to tech.
Some of the kids that are going to
libraries to look things up, um,
on shared computers, some have
different access in their homes. Um,
we also tried to deal a lot with kind
of the generational divide in terms of
comfort levels because I also feel like
a lot of times when you talk to adults
about tech, they immediately go to a
place of fear. They're overwhelmed,
they're anxious, like a parent's.
We immediately think screentime bad,
I feel guilty.
But kids don't live in that world.
They don't feel fear and anxiety about
tech. Like the future is fun for kids.
And,
uh,
so I also really had to come to the
show from that divide of like trying to
overcome my own anxieties and guilt as
an adult in this world and to try to
think from the perspective of
kids. So, um, yes, and every,
all the projects that we're working on,
we definitely try to address the digital
divide and the generational divide.
But I,
I really appreciate you bringing that up.
Okay.
Other question.
I know there's a few ads there.
Can we talk about, I have
odd way that's super fun. Um,
so my dream in life was with
never really to like work in tech,
although I blended my dream in life was
to sing on Broadway and then I got to
college and I got rejected
from the music major,
flat out rejected and they
were like, don't feel bad.
Yo Yo ma also got rejected.
I was like, cause I don't know, it
doesn't make me feel any better.
Like I feel just as bad.
Um, and uh, I thought I had given
up on my dream. I was like, okay,
by dream singing on Broadway.
And then I moved out to California and um,
I know you guys are
familiar with the hackathon.
So at one hackathon at Facebook I
created an eighties rock band called feed
bomb.
And our motto was we play for free and
you get what you pay for pretty mediocre.
But about two years ago,
I got a call in my living room from the
producers rock of ages on Broadway 80.
It's rock musical.
And they were like,
we saw your feed bomb videos and we're
looking for a new kind of guest star for
our musical who can kind of
bring in a social media audience.
Do you want to come star on Broadway?
So after um,
all of that, uh, my,
sometimes you give up on your dreams
and they come back and find you.
But now it's fun because I owe, people
always come up to, you're like, Randy,
how do you get to Broadway?
And I'm like,
can you learn to code?
You got some Broadway.
Sorry.
I was wondering if you're worried about
the increasing prevalence of consumption
only devices. Like as an example, when I
was very young growing up, like it was,
uh,
easier to write a hello world program
in basic on like an old Ms dos computer.
Like that was easier than trying to
figure out how to make the CD rom drive.
We can load in windows suite I
want for instance. But nowadays,
like I'll be on the subway and there's
all these kids playing with iPads and
phones and whatever, but you can't
really program them on the device.
And I have the feeling that they don't
have access to like a real computer at
home either.
Yeah.
So was it like his program and becoming
less accessible for young kids? He stays.
That's a great question cause I think,
um,
on one hand that question sort of goes
back to the question we just had about
the digital divide because we have to
look at the rest of the world beyond just
us. And I mean there are many parts of
the world that are skipping computers
entirely because mobile phones are all
that people have access to. I mean,
there's more mobile phones
than toilets in the world. Um,
and but many countries like when you look
at India and Africa are just skipping
the computer entirely. So
on one hand we need to, uh,
I think you are right that we
are missing some part of that,
but I think we also need to adapt to the
world and to the changing environment
that people are,
um,
program that they are using mobile
devices and that is where they're getting
their content and using
everything. And so, um,
I think you've just hit on
a big opportunity for, uh,
for entrepreneurs who are creating the
next, uh, coding platforms. Thank you.
Well, we have great, hi, my
name is yen and I am a recent graduate.
I want to ask you like how do you,
um,
face failures and how do you,
what kind of power do you use to lift
yourself up in the moments of, you know,
insecurities,
um,
maybe a job rejections
or some kind of failure?
Well, first of all, congratulations.
I'm being recent Grad. Um,
it's everything that I've done.
I have entered a new industry,
so like I have no business being in
the children's television industry.
Like I'd never hosted a radio show.
Everything that I'm doing,
I'm doing for the first time.
So I feel like I'm,
the one certainty is that people are
going to say no to you and you're going to
fail. And so like, Yay, we
got that out of the way.
Like we can move on and we know it.
Um,
what I've also learned is that sometimes
things that look like failures years
later you realize they weren't.
And that, so for example,
right after I started Zuckerberg media,
I created a show on bravo
called startups silicon valley.
It was a terrible show. Like it was
really bad. It lasted one season.
It did not get renewed. Um,
and I was like, I failed.
My first television show
I made was a bomb. Like,
how am I going to pick my head up
and go back into this industry?
And I realized down the line like a,
about a year or two later that first
of all, um, people in Hollywood,
they didn't see that as a failure.
They were like,
you got a show to series as
a first time. He pee. Like,
that's awesome. And, uh,
it created a relationship for me with
NBC who now today is producing sprout.
I mean, and, and dot many years later. Um,
and so it took me awhile to like
scrape myself off the floor,
but without doing that show,
there's no way that I would be doing any
of the things that I'm doing today in
media or half those relationships
or be taken as seriously. So, um,
it's a, I think the, the,
the real thing is to be able to endure
when you're in that scrape that floor
moment to try to see what
lies 10 chest moves beyond
king of what lies beyond, Oh, as
do we have another question? Great.
We'll take one more and then
we'll take that year. Um,
so I sometimes feel that networking
and mentorship can be a little forced.
Um, I think Sheryl Sandberg said it
best. You don't go up to someone and say,
will you be my mentor? You kind of bring
that relationship forms over time. Um,
I'm in the process of starting working
on an idea and I've found myself googling
last night,
like women organization,
entrepreneurial programs and like
random things were popping up.
I was wondering if you
had any recommendations of
networks in the city that
bring women together for
entrepreneur programs?
I just would love outside
perspective of Google.
While I love I'd my colleagues here,
I think it's good to get outside
perspective. Okay, great question.
And one that I'm sort of still
digging my feet into as a newcomer.
But one thing I think you brought up
that's so important is that I think we're
told in the beginning of our careers like,
look for that Pie in the sky mentor
that's going to like fall of all of your
career problems for you and guide
you on this path. I'm sorry,
but every time I've ever
found a person like that,
they haven't disappointed the hell out
of me. Like they don't, first of all,
careers are changing all the time.
Like the careers that will exist in
10 years from now don't exist today.
So how would that person even know to
guide you on that path? Um, and uh,
those people also, they're
busy. They don't have the time.
I have found that the best mentors
I've ever had and been my peers,
and it's been in creating groups of peers
that work in similar industries that
you can bounce things out
of. And, and over the years,
those people rise together.
Suddenly they're the
leaders in the company.
They're the people that
people want to network with.
And I have just had so much more success
in my own career building peer networks
rather than searching for that like
mentor 18 levels up for me. So,
um, I'm going to look into some, some
groups for you because I should know this.
That's something I should know,
but I definitely encourage you also
to maybe like start your own even peer
circles. Great. So we're gonna wrap up,
but TV shows, radio shows
and the books, more TV shows.
What is next?
Broadway to Broadway.
I am producing my first
Broadway show, uh, this fall.
It's called Dear Evan Hansen.
It's actually a musical about
cyberbullying that doesn't
sound like a really fun
thing to have a musical about, but
it's a beautiful show. Um, and, uh,
one of the stars this from pitch
perfect, which we love and, uh,
it's so I'm really excited to be
actually on the producing side of,
of a show on Broadway.
Um,
I have a project coming out soon that
is around the election and women and
girls, um, which I'm excited about.
And then I'm really excited to
see where dot goes from here. Um,
hopefully it will inspire a lot of other
great content because the change isn't
going to happen just from one show there.
It needs to be 500 shows like dot
everywhere. So, but I'm thrilled.
I'm especially in just really thrilled
to be here chatting with likeminded folks
like you guys who are really thinking
about this and who have the power to make
a difference in the space. It's really
an honor and it's exciting to be here,
so thank you. Well, thank you again so
much for spending your afternoon.